[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
Українська земля мене кликала.
[Потутори,
Галичина]
Я люблю працювати зі землею.
Нас було кілька друзів у Швейцарії,
котрі створювали асоціацію
[Крістіна Лібергер
Фермерка, засновниця «Чаї з Потутор»]
задля підтримки агрокультури в Україні.
Цей проєкт пов'язав моє життя з Україною.
Якби я хотіла, то могла б
повернутися додому через рік.
Але я вирішила лишитись тут.
Мені подобається тут.
Це моя робота.
Поки що ще не все вийшло,
але я думаю, все вдасться.
Я хотіла щось створювати.
Розумієте, щось таке,
що я пробую тут робити.
Все життя я працювала вчителькою,
була матір'ю, займалася дітьми.
Хотілося чимось іншим
спробувати зайнятися.
У Швейцарії, де були мої городи,
кріп був дуже цінною
і рідкісною рослиною.
Майже не родило.
Майже не було можливості вирощувати.
Тут — це бур'ян.
Дуже цікаво.
Тут і шавлія, і ромашка, і майоран.
У нас на городі росте
близько 50 різних видів рослин.
У мене не було бізнес-плану.
Я тільки приблизно знала,
в якому напрямі хочу рухатися.
Перший і другий рік
я робила все самотужки.
Від початку до кінця —
до упакування.
Пізніше з кожним роком я вдвічі більше працювала,
тож із часом долучилося більше людей.
Перший крок для трав — це город.
Вирощувати і збирати врожай.
Наступний крок — це сушіння.
До сушки ми і йдемо.
Так, це сушка.
Тут хвощ польовий.
Ми його збирали на природі,
це піде на експорт.
Наразі ми сушимо тільки тут.
Повітря вже надто вологе.
Шипшина і мальва.
Пахне десь любисток,
але я його не бачу.
Десь зверху любисток, він пахне.
Називається цей чай «Квітка».
Вони роблять усе руками.
Бо коли машина упаковує чай,
то вона ламає трави.
Руки краще відчувають,
ніж будь-яка машина.
Коли я відчуваю, як це смакує,
я пробую дізнатись,
який настрій природи туди підходить.
Це концепт для назв чаїв.
Кожна назва розказує щось про красу природи,
про настрій, який ти там знайдеш.
«Ранок срібносяйний»,
«Вечір золотий», «Квітка»,
«Зимові візерунки»,
«Світанковий промінь» і «Дари природи».
Туди ми додаємо все, що залишається.
Від початку метою швейцарських колег
було створення навчального господарства.
Ми співпрацюємо
з місцевою владою та школою.
В них ми позичаємо парти
і стільці шкільні для навчання.
[Іван Бойко
Директор підприємства «Жива земля Потутори»]
До нас приїзджали лектори
з Франції, Швейцарії.
Розповідали про біодинаміку: що це,
як вона розвивається, чим вона є.
Цілий курс базувався у нашому господарстві.
Він став рідним домом для пілотних господарств
та охочих вільних слухачів.
А ось цей майданчик...
До нас час від часу приїзджають діти
з вальдорфських шкіл Швейцарії.
Десь 9–10-ті класи. Вони роблять такі проєкти.
Оце дитячий майданчик у вигляді корабля.
Промальовані хвилі, корабель.
Дитячий корабель пливе у майбутнє,
в море, в океан.
Тут дуже цікаво.
Є гарні сторони тут
і погані, звісно.
Люди не звикли думати самостійно
і брати відповідальність.
Це, звісно мене, інколи нервує.
Але в Швейцарії теж є проблеми.
Де ти живеш, там ти маєш бути на 100%.
Я навіть не питаю себе,
чи подобається мені тут чи ні.
Тут дуже цікаво.
Дуже багато можливостей.
І цим Україна цікава.
Треба трішки грошей —
можна багато чого зробити.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Оператори
Артем Руско, Павло Мудрий]
[Режисер Микола Носок
Звукорежисер Павло Пашко]
[Режисерка монтажу
Людмила Кучер]
[Музика
Panivalkova]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]